our friend Jeff Passan back on the show
how are you Jeff I'm excellent rich I'm
asking the same question right now I
wish I had a great answer for you and
what are they thinking what are we doing
what are they doing
ahh I will be able to tell you 50 hours
from now when the trade deadline has
passed because I think looking at this
Marcus Stroman trade in a vacuum right
now I think it has a lot to do with what
the Meuse next they make are they
looking to win in 2020 how are they
looking to win in 2020 is it with Noah
syndergaard is it with that with Diaz
those are the big questions right now
with the Nets and they have hijacked the
pitching market by going out as a non
contender and getting a guy who
everybody thought was going to go to one
of the contending teams that needs
starting pitcher do the Mets think they
can contend now that they're six out and
they figured that they that they do if
they do keep syndergaard or wheeler or
and that they would still have a big
three that they could do battle with and
if they flip syndergaard they would have
a whole bevy of of prospects that would
replenish more than replenish whoever
they gave up for Stroman I mean is that
the strategy here that's one of the
possibilities there are so many
different iterations you can go down
rich they can trade Zack wheeler as a
pending free agent is not going to sign
a contract extension they can trade
wheeler and cinder guard they could
trade just cinder Garden hope with
wheeler that and a really weak National
League they can make a run here I don't
see that being a mall together likely
it's not just the fact that there's six
games back it's that they've got six
teams ahead of them for that second wild
card spot two and team set frankly on
paper are better than them now you've
got a team like the San Francisco Giants
that on paper probably is not better
than them but let's remember this mess
team the reason that these trades are
even being considered in the first place
is because they've been so disappointing
to this point so why all of a sudden 105
games into the season are they going to
flip a switch and change I just I don't
see that being a reality despite the
protestations of Met fans otherwise you
say hey let's go for it you know we've
got five big starters T the masses
coming off a shutout let's just ride it
out I don't see that at so why is Cindy
are available why well I think it's
because if you look at the rest of the
market rich it's really not very good
there are not a lot of potential
frontline starters out there you know
Cleveland talking with teams about
Trevor Bauer I think it's probably more
likely though that he goes in the
offseason and and when you go to the
next year you've got Mike miner and
Robby ray both of whom have a year of
control lasted are good but not
potentially a frontline guy like Noah
syndergaard well again what about
syndergaard
did the Mets just not want to pay him
they or they can't afford it because
they've already paid to do with money I
think that's more to do with opportunity
cost
you know Noah syndergaard still has the
stuff of an ace yeah and when you have
as many teams out there as you do that
needs starting pitching we can talk
about the New York Yankees they're
probably not trading into him we could
talk about the Minnesota Twins who have
royce Lewis at outs Carroll often their
systems to guys who would be perfect for
the Mets more Lewis who's a shortstop
than cure loss is a left-handed corner
outfielder and first baseman you've got
Milwaukee and the Brewers really don't
have a deep farm system but they have a
need for a starting pitcher and you've
got San Diego in Atlanta that the Padres
are not contending this year but they've
got arguably the best farm system in
baseball certainly one of the top two
and have plenty of felt and then you've
got the Braves who have got arms and
christian pasha andrew waters two
outfielders who the netsertive used
there's a lot of talent to be had for a
guy like syndergaard right now and i
think it's perfectly reasonable that
they have him out there on the trade
market but you're also remember trading
him probably for 80 cents on the dollar
considering he's in the midst of his
worst season and the one thing that the
Mets don't want is Noah syndergaard to
go somewhere where he's going to be like
Gerrit Cole and turned into an ace like
he did when he went from Pittsburgh to
uses Jeff Passan from ESPN here on the
Rich Eisen show at the trade deadline
Zia mentioned moments ago 50 hours away
Bumgarner what do you think the Giants
have caught fire
where I thought for sure he would be on
the market and the Giants would be
sellers where do things stand with a
couple days remaining with one of the
Great's of all-time yeah I think a lot
of people myself included agreed with
you I mean as of a month ago the Giants
were dead in the water then they decided
to become the best team in baseball and
they've been that over the last month at
the same time rich the Giants are 26 and
10 in one-run games it's ridiculous and
it's probably not particularly
sustainable even though they do have a
really good bullpen that being said you
need to get a lot if you're gonna be
training Madison Bumgarner for a couple
of reasons number one because he is an
iconic player in the franchise you know
he's won three World Series and really
almost single-handedly by himself
brought them the 2014 championship but
beyond that you don't want in the midst
of a run like this to say to your
Clubhouse to say to your fans they say
to everyone who follows Giants yeah you
know we're gonna punt just to get
something back now if the Giants hold on
to Bumgarner they'll give him the
qualifying offer and they'll get a third
around or so drafting out of it and
about $800,000 in bonus money and that's
all well and good but you're gonna need
a lot more than that in return and I'm
not sure at this point that teams are
that compelled despite the paucity of
starters out there to give that much up
for a free agent to be well I mean
unless you have an opportunity to win it
right now and you know if you're the
Yankees if you're Brian Cashman you look
around and you got a team that can hit
like crazy if they can stay healthy but
in the long run you know you're gonna
have to pay judge you know you're gonna
have to pay Kleber Torres you know
you're gonna have to play pay Gary
Sanchez you know that you did the right
move by not going for Machado waiting to
see if didi Gregorius could be healthy
and he's been just terrific you know
you're gonna pay him
and you know that you got Erin Hicks
already under contract so you got a
bunch of prospects in the farm that you
don't really have spots for in the next
two three four years but you know that
you got an ace who's hurt you know you
got a thirty nine-year-old playoff
warhorse who's on the injured list and
you know you got a pitcher in Tanaka who
had a performance on Thursday I didn't
Fenway like it was the 1999 home run
derby all over again
so why don't you make this move if
you're Cashman right now rust right now
and and go for it
yeah I think that's a perfectly
reasonable stance to take and something
that the Yankees are mulling over at
this point and you have two guys in
Clint Frasier and Miguel Andujar who if
not entirely proven big-league players
you know they've both got big-time flaws
on the defensive side but they both can
really hit and if you're the Giants and
you're looking to rebuild right now then
you certainly are looking for that type
of guy who's going to be major-league
ready and is under team control for a
number of years so they do match up well
but if the price is too high rich on
those starting pitching the Yankees have
the ability to go out and fortify their
bullpen and it's a good bullpen already
but I I don't think it's beyond the
realm of possibility that they don't go
out and get a starter and instead spend
some of that capital on relief pitching
and understand that in October these
days you don't necessarily need great
starting pitching to win like it helps I
mean if I'm the Houston Astros right now
and I've got Justin Verlander and Gerrit
Cole and Wade Miley who's pitched really
well this year going into a playoff
series I'm more comfortable than what
the Yankees have in their starting
rotation but you also know that with
those days off and the abundance of them
in October you can really tax a bullpen
and ride it all the way to the World
Series and then in the National League
the Dodgers you got the Nationals
obviously the Cubs and Cardinals are
locked in they have the same exact
record right now the Brewers just a game
behind I mean who do you think is going
to make a move out of out of these
groups Jeff
I think all of them make lives it just
depends on these eyes at the Meuse and
and you know you look at a guy like
Robbie ray from the Arizona Diamondbacks
I think when it's all said and done he's
probably billing to move and you wonder
if the Cardinals are fit they're the
Yankee seemed like a pretty decent fit
there there are definitely some
possibilities the the Cubs would love to
make a big move it's tough to say if
they have the capital to go out do so
and matchup with the Mets for example
with Edwin Diaz and what they're looking
for for him which is a pretty high-end
prospect and some other value pieces
there they're not going to get back what
they gave up for him and Jared Kelly
Nick and Justin done but I think they
could do really well because Dodgers are
in on that as well and the Red Sox -
Edwin Diaz the name that's been floated
around and you know the closer we get to
July 31st the more I wonder is he really
going to get no I'm wondering Jeff Jeff
passing a couple more minutes left here
with ESPN's Jeff Passan
on the Honda inside a report on the Rich
Eisen show I mean does any team have a
young arm sitting there in triple-a that
they're gonna say you know what screw it
instead of giving up the prospects for a
so-called proven commodity let's let's
see if we got a kid who's ready to come
up and be dominant and win five six
games and become a new folk hero in
august-september if not october or any
team have that ability yeah it's funny
the New York Yankees actually and David
Garcia is a guy who started off in a
ball this year and has just dominated
his way up the chain to triple-a at this
point the only five foot nine he's only
170 pounds but he's got a big fastball
and a really good curveball and I don't
know if he's gonna come in as a starter
necessarily but if the Yankees don't
trade him and they really don't have any
intention to do that at this point it
wouldn't it all surprised me to see him
in a multi inning sort of fireman relief
role the the Oakland A's have a j-pop
coming off of Tommy John surgery and
NDA's are right on the cusp of that
wild-card spot right now so they could
theoretically fortify that rotation with
him the Houston Astros thought that they
were going to have Forrest Whitley who
came into the year as the top pitching
prospect
baseball but he's been a mess all year
long and I don't think he's gonna get
traded necessarily but the the hope that
Whitley was going to be there to join
Cole and Verlander just as not faring
Trude so last one for you Jeff crystal
ball it most likely maneuver involving
the biggest name player over the next
two days would be what here's a Jeff
Jeff here's if you peg it I'll replay it
and say you nailed it
if you don't this never happened how
does that sound that's that's really how
life works isn't it well it's my
backstop for you let me be your battery
made here this is my backstop for you
here
so it's fire away fire away this is
total this is total old takes exposed
material right here yeah but I don't
care we shouldn't care about that stuff
don't care don't care as long as you're
giving your honest opinion that's all
you're not just doing this just to throw
anything against the wall I'm asking you
give me your best prediction if you get
it right I'll replay it if not this
never happened what do you got for me
what do you think all right if I'm if
I'm just throwing something against the
wall that I could see getting done just
Edwin Diaz goes to the Dodgers ok I'll
be huge Dodgers knit Dodgers Dodgers
need another relief arm they would like
a left-handed one and sorry Felipe
Vasquez is another possibility they're
Will Smith is another possibility it
looks like Riedel Iglesias from the Reds
is going to move but I think the the
real hammer here would be Edwin Diaz the
guy who's had a down year but who could
really bring a good return for the Mets
all right so I lied this is not the last
one what are the what are the chances
that nothing happens like what are the
chances that for the first time in a
long time like hardly zero happens that
everybody just decides they're not
sellers and the buyers just think it's
just too expensive and they're just
gonna stick with what they got what do
you think to be honest I actually think
that is the likely or outcome here I was
talking with the general manager earlier
today who is saying everybody is so
conservative right now prospects have
never been more valuable to teams and
everybody thinks more or less the same
because they're all operating off of the
same models and if that if that holds
the
and Marcus Stroman may ultimately be the
biggest name that gets dealt and that'll
have happened on the 28th as opposed to
the 30th the 31st and then man my head's
everyone will be scratching heads about
what the Mets are thinking but you know
bless him hopefully they wouldn't flip
some some some baseball games and make
the playoffs who the hell knows you
never know Jeff thanks for the call
really appreciate it great work as
always pleasure is always mine that's
Jeff Passan at Jeff Passan on Twitter
follow him I do it's a great follow for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app